so you're home with uh with three kids
there how's
how's it been during uh the isolation
time with all you guys
um it's been it's been
terrible watching people suffering the
way they have you know and the way
the world's fallen apart on a personal
level they've been here they haven't
been here
you know i share them and um
so it's just been a bizarre time i mean
they're just so used to just being in
the house and they've done really good
you know
it's quite it's quite a lot to ask for
anyone let alone young
young kids to just sort of stay put but
we make it fun and we have some
good times and uh so far so good you
know just looking at the news it's just
so bleak
it gets more bleak every day yeah
as far as the conversations go with
regards to like
things that are happening and i'm sure
they're anticipating things like
i want to go see my friends again or i
want to go back to back to normal like
what are those conversations like for
you guys
well all of us all their friends
have been quarantining as well so you
kind of i wonder where it all ends and
and so like my sons fought the elders
who's 14
he has bad practice today and then come
around
and you ask them to practice social
distancing and then you look in the room
and they're all like
go around a computer looking at tick
tock or something like that so it
doesn't work with kids kids do not
have no understanding how to practice
social distance but
it's really hard as a parent like where
when do you start to
say okay your three other band mates
they've also been in their house for
four months and um
you know i mean i don't know if i'm
being reckless but
the the younger two haven't had haven't
seen anyone but the old one is 14 just
being
climbing the walls and so i let him have
a few close friends to come to visit
and uh in no way have they practiced
social licensing they just haven't and
you're like
guys i told you just come on but
i mean it's so hard for them to
understand get their heads around so
it's just trying to deal with it you
know it's just and it's just terrifying
i don't know how it is up where you are
but
um here it's getting worse and worse and
worse it's actually worse than it's ever
been right now
and yet at the beginning of it i was so
terrified i was walking down the stairs
thinking
you know you go outside look at a tree
goes that tree gonna give me corona and
like
your ankle hurts you say did i get it
it's horrific and we've just learned to
live a little bit now
um to the point where um
it's just getting worse and worse i
guess since memorial day and july 4th
stuff
you know i'm
yeah i just saw the post that you put up
where um
someone asked kingston like what's it
like having the king of grunge as a dad
and he said you know he's the best dad
ever like i couldn't ask for a better
dad so there's like two major
compliments there number one
this this kid asks them you know the
king of grunge that's you
that must feel pretty awesome which i
didn't even reference you know i was
thinking
you know i don't know but i i just it
was
just the most beautiful thing he didn't
say he was on his story i saw it on his
story he didn't say it yeah
he just was answering someone and uh i
thought it was just
so beautiful i just was you know it was
incredible
i mean i take it really seriously to be
a father and um
and i'm not sure i'm necessarily that
good at it i'm not sure i'm definitely
not traditional with it
so it's it's incredible to have a 14
year old
who wants to talk to you more than ever
as opposed to that
cliche of them shutting down you know
like yeah looking at the parent anyone
anyone over 21 is the enemy and you know
he just not doesn't understand me that
stuff
and it's the opposite of that which i
think is um
it's beautiful and it's really great
that i have this job and this career
because i think that really helps to
just sort of
you know you just you get this it's like
it's it's like the uh it's like
being peter pan or something you know i
mean it's sort of so young in people's
eyes you know that's cool
yeah well i mean you've been a part of
uh
music lovers lives for decades now
for decades now and you know this is
this is the eighth studio album you guys
celebrated by
doing a like this crazy performance in
an empty venue
which that must have been an interesting
uh experience for you
uh you know i mean i think that you have
to um
survival is about uh adapting
change um invention and change and so
it's how we're doing i do this thing
every week on my
instagram 10 saturday 10 i call them and
people write in with tons of questions
and i just i just choose the ones the
the questions that can let me riff and
walk and then i literally
do stand up for about an hour where i
sit and talk to the screen i mean it's a
relief to be talking to
a human being on the screen because
often i'm like stuck here just
it's got that uh you know chirping away
then you see like 40 000 people watched
it you're like oh man
but it's uh so i feel a little bit more
um
[Music]
versed in uh performing in a vacuum or
talking in a vacuum it doesn't
you know it's the least of it you know
all i have to do is think about the the
the true suffering out there
um health-wise uh you know economy-wise
and i realized that me talking to him
into a vacuum is
pretty dying pretty it's all right it's
okay
it started for performing in that
situation it might be a bit like doing a
video it's like doing
our own tv special so
i was fully aware of that there would be
eyes on me they weren't necessarily in
the room
unless they were working with us and um
so it was okay i mean listen i was so
happy to be able to do something
as a band it was really fun to play all
the new songs and uh
actually you know if you think about it
if we didn't have this uh restriction
i would have um we would have been
playing somewhere or other
so there's been i think about that's up
to a quarter of a million people watched
it now
there's no way that our first show in
toronto
would have garnered 250 000 people i
mean i know we've done one in canada but
i don't think we do that good you know
we're not just
so it was incredible i think it's an
incredible thing because you know i also
was thinking about how
every favorite record of mine i've ever
got is not dependent on their tour
it's not i've never bought a record i'm
all not buying that record unless
they're on tour with my town
you know next three months or else
that's out i've never i've just brought
records
records of bands i loved and um or i'm
intrigued by
and uh so i think it's a bit of a
misnomer
people i think it's because they it
means the radio player stuff
means that all the anti you know goes up
you know
it raises the level um
and uh you know that's just the way this
is the way it goes
um i'm just thrilled to have this record
out i was
i had i was fearful if it was the right
time and
in in the most bizarre way i've never
made such an appropriate record
i mean every record i've made has been
what we've made has been um
in a reflection of where we're at in our
lives and what we're thinking what we're
doing
and people have connected or not
connected whatever they've decided
but with this record the kingdom it just
feels the most
um spot on and prescient record we've
ever made
as far as the kingdom goes how is that a
reflection of where you are
now and where the world is now um
the kingdom was was simply this idea i
just had had enough of being surrounded
by self-righteous judgment people
and had a couple in my life around me
over the last bit of time
and i just imagined a place away from
them
i was like how do i get away from these
people in my life
ever like i don't i just got you know i
got so many kids
i've got friends i haven't seen i've got
family i never see because they're in
england
like this my time and attention outside
of work
uh and the work i love in bush is is so
taken up that like when i was confronted
by being around people
or having to deal with people in my life
that were just like attacking me
and criticizing me and judging me and so
self-righteous i just was like
i just can't i can't imagine how people
get the courage and the confidence
um to be so arrogant you know i just
find it a quality
that is really disappointing people like
if somebody if i
come across someone i can sense that
from them i just i don't even i used to
be
much more confrontational when i was
younger and would want to win someone
over and
show them how i thought this and why
would they think like that now i'm just
like
okay laters i'm gonna go where the grass
is green
and like you know i love these people
and everyone's cool and we're all
we're free and you're not um you know
you're not a racist and you're not
homophobic and you're not
uh you know against minorities and
people just be themselves and flourish
because
i have so many uh interesting um
and varied friends who
cannot take the test of of judgment
from from from people it would it
inhibits them and i don't want to
inhibit people i want to sort
i think we get the best out of each
other when we let each other be there
was some guy who was like
harassing me on my page this morning you
know in this
religious zealot and saying that i was
going to hell and i was like
well that's cool you think that but what
you know
why you follow me i'm not the guy